on Monday show Shirley said he had
trouble believing details of Brent's
winging story and our fans seemed to
agree with it really I'm shocked by this
I thought he was credible Shirley you
seem to have led people down a path
where they're not believing Brent I let
him down
yeah you did all I did was voice a
couple questions that's all you were a
dick
you're a complete [ __ ] my wife and I
are so number one my wife would never
allow me to come in tell a [ __ ]
story number two I have way too much
respect for everybody that works on this
show and this show to come in here and
fight and do that I'm not gonna come in
here waste your time and everybody's
time like by saying [ __ ] do you
believe the whole story is a fabrication
or porting parts of it I don't think
they went out I think what you think
they met a couple right I don't think
the deal was closed what an [ __ ]
what a [ __ ] it yeah you are serious
or you just said busting balls there's
certain parts of the story that are very
convenient
all of it's true 100% true everyone okay
if that means anything it does because
your show you mean it means more than
this [ __ ] like if somebody comes in
here and repeatedly calls you a liar
you're gonna be pissed he did nothing to
verify the stories just making sure can
I suggest something to verify no okay a
lie detector you wouldn't take the word
of the swinging couple couple you mean
the huben the people here people here
have talked to him though surely you
[ __ ] I haven't so what so I will
believe his story
you still like these masses allied
attack [ __ ] Oh maybe Brent in order to
satisfy the Shu Lee's of the world and
Shirley started this whole thing yeah he
did well bring in the couple that you
sponsor are you gonna believe them
listen if somebody's willing to publicly
say that they bang Brent I'm in Julie by
saying it's a fake story
what holes do you see in it okay first
of all uh the guy the guys packing less
than him that's the truth and I'm am
sorry fact that you even put that into
the story it's ass tells me you went out
of your way to make sure you were the
hero and that the pie was asked a
question of meaning what
more believable to the guy had a bigger
penis or if he said hey you know what I
really wasn't looking at his [ __ ] there
was a lot going on been honest right
because anybody in the situation like
that's gonna look are there any other
holes you've seen the story now's your
chance to get it out yeah Paul Columbo
the fact that this picture was taken or
this couple but yet they weren't in the
picture with this cop you can't take
your cell phone into these areas in a
swingers club stupid that don't want to
be photographs oh you're not allowed to
bring yourself on it oh no because you
know there's people there that are there
on the down-low and you could taking a
picture of you and in the background
people in a good point he's got a permit
that say do not use your cell phone you
get very angry very defensive like
somewhat you know next time he swings
you want to tag along as a reporter and
so you can so you believe it I want to
see the rejection in person but there's
been there's never been one rejection so
that's again another shuli lie yeah but
when you don't close the deal the girls
cut the deal stupid you know the other
person is going around saying he doesn't
believe you as long as it will happen oh
wow it just sounds a little the delivery
and it just sounds a little choppy to me
it smelly since I was my first [ __ ]
at 16 I could give you a play-by-play
like it happened five minutes ago
right but can you do it with Shirley
[ __ ] nagging you the whole time this
is what I think happened I think you
went to the club I think you met
somebody and I think we need to get
Julie off of our back let's say we
[ __ ] I would never do that
I'm telling you Sal I'm giving you I'm
telling everybody here on my honor as a
United States [ __ ] Marine go
ahead I did not embellish one [ __ ]
word of that story not one well then BRE
word is true now whether you might
believe in costly [ __ ] help if you
don't believe in no I
can't help you if she always an [ __ ]
and he doesn't [ __ ] believe it would
it be unreasonable if we called robert
muller to do a special investigation the
FBI the CIA the NYPD investigate a
[ __ ] way till the cows come I wish I
believed you that's all I'm gonna say
Sal you know he's I believe Brett III
was questioning it I'm a little scared
but you know he's a man of integrity not
sound believe it that's why you're in
here all right he's a [ __ ] liar